un écran de smartphone qui vient se
plier en forme de U c'est le flex g
c'est bizarre ça peut être le flexible
mais c'est le flex g c'est pour jouer
une fois de plus sur la modularité c'est
Samsung qui nous présente ça alors je
vous ai parlé du flex S qui vient se
plier comme un accordéon et si c'est
plutôt des clapets qu'on vient rabattre
l'un sur l'autre pour gagner une fois de
plus en taille puisqu'on peut le payer
dans un sens on peut le plier dans
l'autre sens je trouve ça extrêmement
malin c'est marrant c'est Samsung
display qui vient nous présenter cette
technologie est-ce que vous pourriez
l'imaginer vous avoir un appareil comme
ça on vient faire un peu comme les deux
volets de son smartphone et l'ouvrir et
d'avoir une énorme tablette pourquoi pas
parce que ça pourrait vous tenter
d'ailleurs marquez moi ça en bas dans
les commentaires en bas sur le côté en
haut en bas où vous voulez dans les
commentaires en tout cas vous me Marquez